[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
my good friend Ken Coleman this is your
show America so make it happen give us a
call at 8825
5225 and we'll help you take the right
Next Step for your money your work and
your life and my friend Ken here he is
the expert on helping you get to that
work that you love helping you get that
bigger shovel help you work on that
greatest wealth building tool your
income so please call in with your
questions for Ken as well Absol and uh
we we love being together people a lot
of chat are out there on social a lot of
chatter uh we we really do like each
other we have some fun little jokes here
and there and we're going to have fun
today you said to me right before we
started let's have a little extra fun
today that was my encouragement to you
since you're a funy duddy normally
I'm fun Dy it's a great word the
youngsters don't know what that means uh
but we're going to help some people
today so let's get to it and practical
advice that's what we're all about all
right let's do it miles joins us up
first in Nashville Tennessee right down
the road miles how can we help you
today hi yes thanks for taking my call
question I was in an accident on
Thanksgiving oh no okay um you okay and
unfort yeah I'm okay now um so the
vehicle is a total loss and at the
moment I don't have the funds to
purchase another car now I am currently
using a family member's car just to get
back and forth to work but I don't want
to use that for an excessive amount of
time what suggestions do you have um
that you recommend before I
proceed well what the heck happened
within
insurance so yeah so the insurance paid
out I in the gap insurance essentially
it paid out what I owed on the vehicle
so I I broke even now I'm starting fresh
all over again with another
vehicle what kind of income are you are
you
making um I do about 45 a month is that
before tax or after tax uh before tax
I'm sorry okay how quickly can you save
up money for a car be realistic
um um honestly um I I couldn't really
tell you and the reason being is because
the vehicle was was part of the biggest
uh expense that I had uh so I haven't
even gone a full month uh of seeing what
what my income would look like without
that without what was your car
payment so the car itself was about
270 um but then because of the type of
vehicle I had I paid 400 bucks a month
in insurance so I was like like I guess
Collective right at 600 a month so 270
plus to four so you're talking you freed
up 670 a month plus gas plus maintenance
and repairs and so we can at least put
that towards the savings on top of
whatever margin we can find with this
income do you have any other
debt uh I've got some some older debt
some personal loans some credit cards
that I've been actively paying down uh
now I'm probably right at 10 uh total
for all that $1,000 in debt still
correct and I'm assuming nothing in the
bank paycheck to paycheck right
now uh got about maybe 1,500 in savings
at the moment okay that's a start so
let's let's say you got this thousand
starter emergency fund you have 500
bucks left over and now we're going to
get to the point where the our One
Singular goal we're going to make
minimum payments on the rest of our
debts right now we got to get you some
transportation and that might mean
you're going to go down to your mechanic
and go hey guys I'm looking for the most
beater of the beater cars that you got
someone gave it to you for parts and you
guys are trying to just fix it up and
sell it uh do you have anything like
that hanging around I'd be calling every
mechanic and dealership you know
independent dealership around to see
what they have and what the lowest price
car is and you might find one for 3 four
grand okay and you could save up 3 four
grand in a few months if you freed up
that payment plus the margin you have
from your income making payments bu get
busy selling stuff
J making more money like right now
you're trying to come up with 20 30
hours a week of hourly work to get this
car funded I'm pulling up you know I
love to do this is my favorite thing to
do use cars for sale in Nashville under
5,000 well I tell you this miles I've
confidence because I helped a Ramsey
team member here get a car for two grand
not long ago right and it's not a flashy
vehicle but it's it's running it's still
how are you driving
before uh a 2018
Sonata all right and how long can you
drive this family
vehicle um they're they're patient and I
can tell their patient uh but I kind of
want to get it back to them relatively
quick would they be okay for four months
if they didn't have this
vehicle uh I probably say maybe two
months
Max okay well I would get real good
Clarity with them say hey I'm trying to
save up here's my goal my goal is to get
get you this car back in a few months
what's the urgency when do you guys need
this back by let's get some realle facts
I I almost wonder if they wouldn't be
willing to uh to have you pay for the
car a little bit you know what's this
car worth could you buy it from them or
is it too nice of a vehicle for you
right
now so we talked about that as well um
about the the opportunity of me buying
it they declined on that because they
want to keep it as a backup vehicle in
case theirs goes down they only have one
vehicle as well what's your commute like
as far as work goes
um 10 miles so not not far at all like I
said worst case scenario I could walk if
I have to but I know it's going to be
getting pretty cold here pretty soon
sure but you could also you know if you
had to Uber for a few weeks that's not
going to be a deal no no Uber walk I'd
rather him walk than Uber have you
walked 10 miles Ken have I walked it
I've never walk 10 miles I've run 10
miles go I'm just saying walking 10
miles in in 28° a point it's the
principle he doesn't need to be spending
Uber money to get to work I'm just
saying worst case if he loses this
vehicle he deal Breer all right I and I
I sound like the kudin all right I'm GNA
I'm going to you're right about the walk
he said it I just went with it I'd get a
bike you can bike in 10 10 miles pretty
quickly yeah I had a buddy of mine that
lived like on my on my bedroom floor cuz
he needed a place to crash and he would
bike to work at TGA Fridays back in the
day and uh he survived to tell the tale
it's been done before this guy is in a
situation here where he's got a scramble
yeah and so you can come up with it but
I'm telling you I'm looking at cars
right now well I can tell Miles you
don't you want to 3500 will get you a
decent car for a season you know yeah
I'd start I'd start looking around start
doing your homework while working these
side jobs but my guess is within three
or four months you've got a beater car
and that's okay and 6 months after that
you can upgrade that by a few thousand
bucks and you're going to be out of debt
soon and this will be a blip in the uh
grand scheme of your life but I hate
that you're going through this man but
I'm glad you got also got rid of the car
payment that's a rough way to do it but
you just freed up 700 bucks a month my
man yes sir I appreciate it thank you
for taking my call yeah best of luck
with this situation and there's a lot of
local uh dealerships and mechanics can
that I think would be happy to let go of
a vehicle that has been sitting on their
lot that needs some work but I mean
listen the bottom line is if you looking
for cars under three grand they're all
over the place Facebook Marketplace
Place yeah it's true they're out there
man oh man cars he's going to have to
get some really good walking shoes I
would do I'd probably buy a bicycle how
long would it take you to walk 10 miles
uh my little legs I'm going to give it
at least 45 minutes is that fair I don't
know I think you speed walk you could
beat that I'm not a marathon I would
love to see you walk 10 miles I'd
outwalk you on any day not a chance
guarantee you I'd outwalk you that's for
another episode of the ramsy show but
for now more calls coming coming up
we'll be right
[Music]
back hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman this
hour the number to call Isle
5225 Ken I errone erroneously said that
I could walk 10 miles in 45 minutes in a
previous call that's that's really
walking fast I looked up the average
time it takes to walk a mile it's about
20 to 30 minutes a mile yeah and I was
going to say the the the the world
record for the fastest mile is what I'm
not sure about that but the average
walking speed is about 3 miles an hour
and so right that's average you don't
know my speed walking ability but like
the fastest mile of all time I think is
just under four minute mile I think and
so what he said but we were all just
combobulated cuz I was just generally
saying I was playing the Boomer rle you
should walk all I could think all I
could think as soon as he said it I went
I did 17 12 miles in 7 hours there's no
way he's going 10 Mes in 45 minutes
George is a quick one though he's quick
they're little but they are quick my
friends them Feats be nimble them Feats
be nimble I love it oh it's too much fun
we're already having fun let's see if we
can screw some more stuff up K all right
what you say let's go to Renee in Miami
what's going on
Renee hi um how are you thank you for
taking my call we're doing
well good good quick question um I've
made a little bit of money this year um
I don't really have any debt other than
maybe 15,000 that I owe on a car um and
I have a really good accountant that has
advised me to um open up a few different
accounts to put some of that money in um
I have an escort that I opened this year
and um so I'm right now trying to
consider do I need to hire a financial
planner by the end of the year in order
to help me to diver iify and put some of
my income in these different buckets so
you have a pile of money sitting in the
bank right now is that is that what
you're trying to figure out what to do
with it I do all right so hold on so I
thought I heard you say you don't have
any debt except for $15,000 and I'm
confused because that's
debt well it's a car so if I I could
just pay off the car I'm assuming um but
right now so what's been holding you
back from paying off the car
um trying to decide if I want to keep
that car or not but the debt can go
today you can make the car decision
later yeah you're exactly right how much
money are we talking that you have in
the
bank about
150 okay so you got 150,000 that's
pretty much everything to your name in
liquid
cash yeah and what's your
income uh this year uh gross about 200
awesome good for you what do you
do um I'm in mle estate nice way to go
Renee fantastic okay you got plenty of
cash so you shouldn't be holding on to
the car payment just because you're not
sure if you're going to keep it or not
you have enough cash to pay it be debt
free and that's what we teach we want
you debt free before we start
investing okay so if you became
debt-free today and then you put some of
this money aside for an emergency fund
let's say that leaves you with a about
$100,000 is that
fair uh yeah mhm okay so with the
100,000 left uh are you a homeowner
right now do you want to
be um I'm not right now and I do want to
be next year so that's kind of The Next
Step that I'm going to take in the New
Year okay awesome and you're in real
estate so you know the stuff inside out
but what I would do uh you don't
necessarily need a financial planner
right now it's good to to start that
relationship and you may want to open up
you know a Roth IRA because you're on
the cusp of getting ready to start
investing that 15% as soon as we clean
this up get the emergency fund in place
and I assume I would if I'm you I'm
going to use all of that extra money for
the down payment on this home and so I
would leave it liquid in a high yield
savings account in order to do that
which means you don't necessarily need a
financial planner
today okay so my accountant because
again I'm sitting here at December 15
and uh David buys me to open up HSA
401K a rough and a high yield savings a
awesome those are all good things uh
there was no red flags on any of those
and I think you are on the cusp of being
ready to do that in which case I would
start that conversation um we have a
there's a smartvestor program where you
can get connected to investing pros at
Ramy solutions.com so I would advise you
to do that if you want to start to get
the ball rolling figure out which
investment options make sense for you as
a you know
solopreneur self-employed
person yes but you're there but the
thing is with real estate people what I
found found Renee is that they tend to
want to get fancy and complicated and
instead of just following a simple
Proven
Plan okay got it so what you don't want
to do is go invest this money because
someone told you you can make a lot more
you can turn your 100 into 300 instead I
want you to use it toward your very soon
Tobe financial future of being a
homeowner which is going to get real
expensive real quick especially in
Miami yeah so you may need more than
100,000 down in order to afford a house
in your budget what's your car pay pay
right
now oh like 350 so the reason we want
you to pay that off today is because a
you have the cash and now it gives you
even more options because you can sell
that car right now if you want to you
can hang on to it it's not cost you any
money in fact you give yourself a $350
raise per month right out of the gate
yeah but doing what George said get the
emergency fund in place then you then
you sit down and you figure okay what do
I want to say for the house what's my
investment you know the investment
strategy we teach 15% of your your uh
income after you got your debt paid off
and after you've got your emergency fund
set up but you're already able to do
that it's just moving the money around
today literally instantaneous which is
awesome that's the great news this is
not a six-month journey to do all of
this you're going to be there real soon
Renee so keep it up aome job great
income way to kill it let's go over all
the way across the country to Spokane
Washington Sandy joins us there Sandy
how are you I'm good how are you guys
we're doing great how can we help today
good so I I am a homeowner um and I had
a piece of property that was deed to me
20 years ago and I decided I was
probably never going to live on it so I
sold it while the market was kind of up
and I got about 170 for it um I paid off
my car and all the other debts that I
had so now I'm basically debt free
except for my house payment okay um but
I also don't have much of a retirement
because I've always worked in jobs that
just just never worked out I'm 53 so I'm
not a spring chicken so I have this
money sitting there and I'm not sure if
I should put it on the little IRA
rollover account that I have from a job
a long time ago that's got $1,500 if I
should put it on the house I also have
now my student loans due because during
Co I got my Master's in business so I'm
just trying to figure out where are the
best places to put this
$130,000 that I have well first order of
business you just let the cat out of the
bag you still have some debts Sandy you
got those student loans to pay student
loan yeah well it just I literally my
first payment is due this month okay
what's left on the student Lo have
anything yeah what's left on 18 okay so
what would you have left after you pay
off this $18,000 in student loans how
much money uh
about10 okay what's left on the mortgage
yeah uh
$10 okay awesome and you have an
emergency fund on top of that or is this
it it's all tied up in this one well
yeah no it would be I have no because
it's all dumped into savings so out of
that 130 that's in savings I guess 10 of
it would be my emergency okay I'm
probably 100 to be fair 100 student
loans off 10 feels real low for you for
an emergency fund um I would lean
towards three to six months maybe on the
six month side are you single
married um yeah I'm single what's your
income not
enough um it's well I was working at a
job and they laid me off and I took a
$10 cut and pay so what that was like
two months ago so right now I make TW
like under 45 a year okay what were you
making prior so prior to that you're
making over
50 yeah I was making $30 an hour now I'm
making 20 yeah I if I were you I would
George I'd like her emergency fund to be
based on the $30 an hour yeah look at
your household expenses today as they
stand and multiply that by six and
that'll give you that number number that
you need to keep aside from the savings
okay yeah and then we got to get back
get back in the game you know you know
uh You' got a master's degree that's
something and uh I hang on the line I
tell you what I want to do I want to
give her a little bundle little
Christmas bundle I'm going to give her
the get clear work assessment it's going
to really help you with a great job
description an ideal job description for
you based on what you do best and what
you love to do I'm going to give you the
book from paycheck to purpose which will
help you get there once you know what it
is is and I'm going to give you the book
The Proximity principle which is how to
connect with people to get the
opportunity knocking on your door all
three of those gifts from uh me and
Uncle Dave love it and Sandy once you
get the emergency fund I would max out
that that Ira for the year with some
catch up contributions that you have at
your age and throw the rest at the house
and begin that Journey this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill Mortgage
today to learn
[Music]
more welcome back to the Ramsey show I'm
George Campell joined by my friend Ken
Coleman the number to call is
aa825
5225 well Ken we've got some uh some
news here and it's not ramsy news this
is national news from CNN what the fed's
looming rate Cuts would mean for you so
people are starting to get a little
excited at mortgage rates taking a dip
for the first time in a long time uh
they've dropped from 7.03% down to
6.38% in the last 2 months for 15year
fig
loans and here's the article from CNN at
the moment's rates are historically High
making all these loans and credit card
rates and lending super expensive and uh
but there's some economic projections
that the FED would significantly lower
the predicted rates by this time next
year implying three rate Cuts next year
a reverse course for rates has all kinds
of implications for consumers it goes on
to say lower rates could make borrowing
cheaper uh that includes mortgage rates
and uh fed share jome power on a press
conference cautioned that we're far from
a hard Landing scenario but a turn to
lower rates could soften the blow that
higher rates have taken on the US
economy and they go on to say hey this
isn't all good news US savings rates
which have been near their highest
levels this Century would come down if
the FED starts cutting rates so you've
been enjoying your 5% in your savings
account that could come down but there's
also good news because mortgage rates
could come down which has been it's been
a tough think can CU a lot of people are
hanging on to their low interest
interest mortgages
which means less inventory yeah which
means prices go up on top of interest
rates being Sky High it's been a tough
time for want to want to be homeowners
well as we sit here right now the
30-year fixed mortgage rate has dropped
to
7.07% as you said the 15E is at a 6.31
this is today this is today's numbers
right now um and but the reason the
mortgage rate is dropping is because if
we look at the treasury yield and the
bonds and and all that jazz when you
start to see the demand uh kind of slow
down there then you're going to see
mortgage rates drop so what are mortgage
rates going to do over the next year uh
it's hard to say but if you see things
start to move into the sixes and low
sixes you're going to see the shock wear
off for a lot of people who are like I
remember when it was 3 point nothing you
know or whatever and I think that's
going to be interesting to watch as the
real estate market goes so goes the
American economy when we look at housing
and in the form of people refinancing so
we saw a spike in refinance last week
when things got people were already
going they bought like months ago down
to seven 100% so refinancing drives the
mortgage industry uh housing starts mean
means Builders uh people selling buying
homes and then doing the restoration to
either sell it or the restoration after
they buy it that drives a lot of the
economy so it's going to be very
interesting to see what happens but
right now we got some really good
economic news in the last 48 hours and
so it's really interesting to see what's
going to happen but I I think you're
going to see the real estate market
really pick up what's going to happen
though is is I don't know if prices will
drop quickly because right now there's
such a low inventory and there's this
pinup demand you might see another Rush
again you might see a temporary spike in
home values and prices I I mean
selfishly speaking that's what I want to
see but I'm not a young couple and I
know a lot of young people are going man
the price of homes just continues to go
up and I think that's still going to be
the case for a while so I I say all that
to say this I would not wait I would not
have the mindset if I'm able to buy now
I would not wait a year or two years
because I don't think we're going to
ever
see uh well I shouldn't say ever that's
a dangerous word I don't think we're
going to see the interest rates that we
saw over the last 5 years for a long
time yeah twos and threes so for those
of you that want to be homeowners this
could be huge for you because even a
small percentage change that can mean
big savings we're talking thousands and
thousands over time so no one knows for
sure what will happen um but if you've
been sitting on the sidelines and you're
wanting to be a homeowner do it when
you're financially ready and don't try
to time the market and as Dave has said
M uh date the rate and marry the house
you can always refinance if and when
rates do come back down so if you're
debt-free with an emergency fund and you
have that down payment and you can get
that mortgage where the payment's no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay it's time go ahead and do this now
otherwise uh you know if you if you have
the mortgage become 60% of your
take-home pay we've had those calls
that's heartbreaking so don't do it
under pressure don't do it if you're not
financially ready because you'll end up
house poor but you can find a home
within your budget and you can do that
with one of our Ramsey trusted real
estate agents these are these folks are
experts they know the market like the
back of their hand they care about your
financial goals so if you want to
connect with one for free go to ramsy
solutions.com
agents all right let's go to the phones
to Portland Maine Justin joins us there
Justin how you doing today I'm doing
great guys how are you doing great how
can we
help oh first off you two are my two of
my favorite personalities two of Ken two
of yeah well you you really that that
that kind of got that was not a
compliment you started with your my two
and then you I took it as a compliment
two of my favorite there's only five of
us okay we'll take it George George my
only complaint with smart lony happy
hour is that it's only once a week so
I'm sorry we're doing our best out here
lame Rachel hey Justin inside baseball
George is only allowed to have one drink
a week so that's why we do that keep me
limited he can't handle stick to the
mocktails for that reason thank you
Justin you're very kind we appreciate it
what's your question
today yeah so uh short question uh just
to make it simple then we can move on if
we need to so should my fiance and I
move closer to her to her new job even
though rent is
higher um yeah so basically my fiance
and I are pregnant uh baby is due in
April and our wedding is next
October and uh right now we have paused
baby step two and are in super St mode
because of the two St modes um our
finances are separate but to keep it
simple our take-home pay is 6,000 a
month and we are currently saving 2400 a
month for stor mode and uh with our
current rent being 1,00 with everything
included moving closer to her work uh
which her new job is about an hour away
from where we live um the rent goes up
to about 144 to 1,800 a month plus
utilities that's that's that's a long
way to drive an hour huh that's and you
know Ken I knew talking to you you kind
of have that sentiment uh so here's the
thing right I live in Maine and you know
the snow um she's okay with the drive
and that's awesome but I don't know how
I feel about it yeah I don't like it is
she gonna be on some kind of maternity
leave
she is yeah once once the baby comes
she'll be on a six week maternity leave
and I guess that's another layer to it
um I just wonder can we punt this can
she make the drive for a few months then
she's on maternity leave then we can
have this discussion in the summer time
to
move yeah yeah it's not a it's not a bad
idea um that's one option okay so let's
let's run the numbers on this with
George though so so what is the uh it
would be how much more to your budget
for both of you if you made the move to
this new apartment was it $300 more or
did I get that
wrong yeah so the total increase again
things are split but so the total
increase is between three and almost
$700 more depending on what we can find
it's just there's not a whole ton of
rentals uh there's a good amount there's
just not a whole ton and a lot of the
times um you know the the more expensive
you go the more utilities are included
but then there paid off so practical
question so this this apartment these
numbers you're giving me is this based
on apartments that are right there close
so instead of an hour they're five
minutes away because I'm wondering if we
could pull back and go if it's a 20
minute drive or a 15minute drive versus
an hour that's significantly better but
I wonder if the cost is
different yeah so if we were to be five
like within 10 minutes it's going to be
over two grand um the numbers I'm
looking at her are giving her a half
hour commute which I'm much more
comfortable okay gotcha so you're
already thinking that okay but I mean
1,500 out of six that's 25% so you guys
are right on target as far as those
numbers go it it hurts because it's more
than you're paying now but it's not
going to crush you guys
financially okay and do I factor
utilities into that or is that added all
that would just be your your actual rent
utilities would fall outside of that 25%
so you'd be okay um you guys have the
margin to do it but also I wouldn't wait
until October to get
married yeah you're bring a baby into
this world together go to the courthouse
and then have a celebration later on
when you guys are debt free man this is
why you and I should have an online
license we could have done the ceremony
right here on the show on the air Justin
that would have been fun we need to look
into that guys I would love to do that I
think that'd be great you're doing great
you're saving 2400 bucks in the stor
mode until baby and mom are home healthy
that's going to get you guys 10 grand
right there if they're healthy throw it
at the debt continue on we're going to
move on with our life it's quality of
life here George get married today my
friend and congratulations this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George Campell joined by my good friend
Mr Ken Colman the number to call is
5225 well hey it's Christmas time Merry
Christmas to all of our listeners out
there and of course we love to give
great gifts around Christmas time and if
you want some for your family we've got
a killer sale right now the $12 sales
happening where you can get bestselling
books like The Total Money Makeover baby
steps millionaires own your past change
your future Ken Coleman's got some books
on there for just $12 each and we also
have some new stuff in the Ramsey store
Rachel Cruz has a new kids book that is
just going bananas Ken it's called I'm
glad for what I have oh it's a cute book
really sellout and uh that's great news
there our friend Jade warshaw has a new
book called money's not a math problem
that that bright orange one right there
to your left cuz this is the one that uh
I'm a little excited about this bad boy
look at that look at this guy right
there they managed to somehow put you on
a book cover your whole body got in
there it took a a whole team of editors
Breaking Free from broke that's right
George's first book this book is so good
and I'm proud of my friend let me tell
you something folks I've watched George
live this out I've watched te live it
out his whole journey to Ramsey
personality what he does paying off his
house I've been there watching the whole
thing I love this dude cuz he's the real
deal and this book is going to help so
many people uh just get away from the
game The Matrix that's what I love about
this book that means it's all the the
financial wisdom that you would expect
but it's extremely practical and because
it's practical it's hopeful this is an
absolute must purchase if you've got
somebody in your life that just has no
stinking clue about the the the
financial game they just don't get the
game they don't understand that they're
just victims uh in a great marketing fix
that broke is normal in America if they
don't get it but they want something a
little snarkier a little bit more their
speed I think this is a must get for
every college kid in your life Abol
who's coming out and they need to
understand it cuz George speaks the
language and the parents never learned
it so this is a great way for the
parents and their kids to go all right I
got to learn the truth about money
George cuts through the noise that's
what I tempted to do here with a lot of
human research and of course snark but
and you hand this to them and they go
well this is no Boomer talking to me
here no look at that little hipster you
look cool you got your Gap jeans outfit
on I mean Oshkosh BOS jacket you look so
cute it's so great I aim for cute Ken
look at that so anyway go get that
that's that's available at ramsy
solutions.com yes it's on pre-sale right
now we also have Ken some limited
edition autograph copies I signed a few
hundred of those and there's still some
available can you call that a limited
edition well there's only a few hundred
and after that they're done they're gone
you're never going to sign a book again
never again so it's special so you go in
the Ramsey store you can search for for
Breaking Free from broke or Search the
word autograft and you'll find it in
there and uh by the way all my books all
my books will forever be signed if you
want them I'm not going to limit myself
to the people you promise people I will
sign any book your mouth just wrote a a
check that you can't cash my friend I
don't even know what that means but
we'll see I've heard it said before okay
so go check all of that out Ramy
solutions.com
store Now's the Time you can still get
some gifts especially the digital ones
in time for your loved ones for
Christmas Marie is up next in Louisville
that's how we say it Ken is that right
the great state of Kentucky the
Commonwealth of Kentucky there it is
somebody's been paying I appreciate that
Marie welcome to the ramsy show hi thank
you guys so much for having me um I'm
still learning how to say vo the right
way there you go that sounded pretty
good um well I've had a lot of practice
since moving here um been here since
June but anyways thank you guys for
having me um I am just looking for a
little bit of guidance on just how to
attack the debt that I've got myself
into over the past year um I'm 27 years
old and this debt spiral really started
probably at the end of
2022 um I ended up ending a relationship
with a person I own the house with um
won't do that again anybody that um I'm
not married to in the future but um I
really didn't have any debt before then
um besides some student loans and
ultimately I assumed the mortgage and
ended up taking what was in savings um
and buying him out of the house when I
assumed the mortgage um but then fast
forward to this year I had to relocate
out of state for my job without a whole
lot of warning and you know it was
harder for me to save at the time
because I went from splitting bills
50/50 to you know all everything being
on me um and so at that time I had you
know probably piled up a lot more debt
in my um just getting ready to sell the
house and um you know fixing things and
you know in preparation to move um and
with a mentality that like hey when it
sells like I'm just going to be
reimbursing myself and as you can
imagine like with the market like I had
it listed for about five months even
after had moved and I was paying you
know rent and utility in my new city
here in W and then also paying you know
the homes expenses between June and
November um so not being able to save
there either and um so during this time
I also total my car so how to buy a new
car too just ironically but anyway so um
with all of this like my mindset was
just in the place that when I sell my
house I'm going to replenish my like
replenish my savings and pay off all
this debt but that wasn't the case so I
KN now do have a renter in the house to
at least alleviate myself from the
responsibility of like having that
mortgage paid um you know the expenses
for that home being covered um but just
obviously the Quick Fix to my debt
solution would be to sell my house and
get that money but that's not the
situation in right now so um I'm just
trying to get some advice on how to
attack that debt like that how much debt
do you have now outside of the mortgages
outside of the mortgage it's 69,000
total and the breakdown is 24,000 in car
12,000 in personal loans 9,000 in credit
card and the 24,000 in student loan and
before all of this I had just the
student loan so what's your
income um I make between like 140 and
heck yes good for you that's what we
like to hear so Marie why why can't you
sell the house in the other
state I don't does your real estate
agent suck or is the home just
overpriced um I went through two
different real estate agents had it
listed for the five months and did
decrease the price of the home I just
think like the area that I was in there
was way more in inventory sitting on the
market than there were houses actually
being closed and sold and
and I decreased the price often like did
a lot of like analysis around that it
just I kind of think that I it was
probably just poor timing and I didn't
really I wasn't really in control if I
didn't have a job change obviously where
I had to relocate out of state I would
have stayed there you know um so it was
kind of just an unfortunate situation so
I mean I I wish I had the answer to why
how much Equity do you have in that home
um the home is worth about 380 and I owe
about 195,000 on it I got to tell you
kiddo with the uh interest rates
starting to drop I'd be talking I'd be
finding another really good uh real
estate agent I'd be thinking about that
with new George cuz it's out of state
you don't want to be a longdistance
landlord and I want you to be debt free
I mean you can claw out of this pretty
quickly making 160 paying off 69 this is
a solvable problem but you could also
Leap Frog it go to ramsy solutions.com
agent Marie and connect with one of our
Ramsey trusted real estate agents these
folks are rock stars and they'll be able
to help you figure out why this thing
hasn't sold um because with inventory I
know you said it's hotter in your area
but overall people are jonesing to find
a reasonably priced home and to find a
home under 400 in today's world that's
solid is is hard to do so I think this
thing can get sold it's going to help
you get out of debt faster but the key
that you want to focus on right now um
is this debt snowball so how much money
do you have in the bank right now um I
have about 4,000 um I've completely
stopped using the credit cards and since
becoming a landlord had about an $8,000
cash bill I had to pay that wasn't
covered by homeowners insurance four
days after my ten moved in well that's
the problem is you're you're trying to
get out of debt but you're also a
landlord and so you have to have this
little side emergency fund right now to
cover those expenses so I wouldn't tell
you to deplete that to pay down debt in
this weird season that you're in but the
rest of your income is going to go
toward debt you got to cut your
lifestyle down to nothing and if you
want to end up selling the car that's
okay the car is not a huge part of your
world and income right now but it would
alleviate some stress but you're going
to focus on the credit cards first
that's your smallest debt make minimum
payments on the rest once the credit
cards are knocked out move on to the
personal loan and then onto the student
loan and car loan and you can do that
most people do it in 18 to 24 months I
think with your income could you live
off of you know less than half your
income right now and throw the rest at
the debt yeah Pro yeah I mean I I don't
I only use my debit card anyway since
you know October so I think that yes I
can do that for sure I just need to
budget and put a plan together and yeah
if you can throw Seven Grand a month at
this debt it's gone in less than 10
months so that's the math on it but now
we have to get our Behavior to line up
with the math and that's the hard part
of being a human so thank you for the
call maray we are wishing you the best
with this home sale again ramsy
solutions.com agent is the place to go
to get connected with a Ramsey trusted
real estate agent that puts this hour of
the Ramy show in the books my thanks to
Ken Coleman and all the folks in the
booth keeping the show float in new
America we'll be back before you know
[Music]
[Applause]
it
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
bestselling author and host of the Ken
Coleman show you guessed it Ken Coleman
joins me this hour the number to call
Isle
8825 5225 if you've got a question about
your money your work the intersection of
that your life we want to help you take
the right Next Step and Ken is my
favorite person to host with oh thank
you George when it comes to work
questions oh I see how he did that I
left a long pause you see that he pulled
me right in and thought it was a
Hallmark card nope no just a sticker
just a sticker but hey you fell for it
here we are we're at the end of the year
and and a lot of people thinking about
do I start a business in 2024 do I start
that side hustle I finally quit that job
how do I make more money forget the
quitting of the job you want to make
more
money who I'm your guy let's go let's
get that shovel bigger so that we can
get through the baby steps faster and
live the life we truly want to live
that's what I'm here to do so any of
those calls today let's take them let's
do it Lizzy kicks us off in Austin Texas
Lizzie welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my call
I just found out I was um pregnant with
our miracle baby about in on Friday wow
wait a second how why how is this a
miracle baby give us the
story because unfortunately we've had
two miscarriages in the past 13 months
oh and we were actually going to start
doing IVF we save up for IVF but we
actually got back into the FPU and we're
like you know what we're going to put
that to the side and let's just tackle
the debt because we have an overwhelming
amount of debt um mainly business debt
but because everything is personal
collateral I just think it's all
personal debt anyway you would be
correct you're right your name's on it
well congratulations it's
exciting I haven't even told my husband
because I don't even know I feel like I
can't even be excited you told us before
your husband you told you you told these
two clowns and millions of other people
before him I hope he's in a hole
somewhere safely that he can't hear this
when do you plan on telling
him I'm planning to tell him for
Christmas cuz I do want to I have been
doing the blood work and everything just
to make sure everything's going good and
that um we don't have an unfortunate
event again I don't think this is a good
idea I I don't think it's a good idea to
put this out there on the show and then
wait until Christmas to tell him I'd sit
him down tonight with a smile on your
face and say listen I know we 've been
through a lot you're not going to
believe this but here you go I feel like
we should conference call him in and
tell him right now I that's what I think
yeah I wouldn't wait for the myy moment
for him to go you are the father yeah
I'd go ahead and tell him
now okay but that's just two guys
opinion I'm actually gonna meet him here
probably in about an hour before he goes
into work that's a lot for you to carry
that's like your little secret for the
next 10 days Len I I I I want to get to
the debt stuff but I've got to say you
have got to tell him today before he
gets into the off you can't you I feel
guilty like I'm I'm a mess right now our
life studio audience isn't a g they
don't know what to do either don't you
all feel like I so we should tell this
guy I can't bear this this burden is too
heavy the funny thing is too is that he
predicted it about three weeks ago and
I'm like no there's no way and it's too
soon anyway and turns out he was right
well that's when you sit him down and
say this guy called a shot hey honey
your crystal ball was correct you'll
never believe it okay this is the
craziest thing that's ever happened to
me on the show George that's pretty wild
all right but it's an honor that you
trusted us with this secret and millions
of listeners let me gather myself Li the
reason I feel like we can't be excited
or I can't be excited is because we have
50,000 50.5 th000 um in personal like
personal Bill debt on top of that we
have $
6515 th000 of business debt that is all
tied to our personal oh my God what kind
of business debt is it construction debt
and it's um anywhere from credit cards
to to personal loans to uh the 80% of it
is probably friends and family I say
friends and family but honestly it's
more like lone sharks well it sounds
like your friends and family made a
bads uh is this business still afloat is
it doing well where is it it it is is
doing well in the sense of like so and
it's combined Deb of my business with my
business which is also um a construction
business but I keep wanting to sit them
down that's the other issue too is that
I keep wanting to sit them down and talk
numbers but it just ends up being a big
ordeal or we get into an argument and we
just can't seem to come eye to eye and
I've showed them like the plan of what I
because uh I we started doing FPU again
and I'm doing the everyday dollar not
only I got the everyday Black Friday
deal um a dollar Black Friday deal for
the personal finances and then on top of
that I'm also for the business uh so I
got two two of them what is the what's
the household
income the household income for just my
husband and I with his W2 income my W2
income and the business income is about
18,300 a month a month a month and
that's
gross and that's gross that's what we
take home yes okay are you guys paying
your taxes are you putting money aside
for that how's that working so and
that's the other thing uh included in
the in the numbers I gave you that we're
in debt I'm assuming right now we
probably owe about 15 to $16,000 worth
of taxes okay that's going to go to the
top of the debt snowball oh my gosh
that's going to be the first thing you
pay off is the IRS debt and then we're
going to continue on down small Sal
larest balance this is going to be years
and years of
sacrifice yeah one quick question on
this you said W2 W2 so this company
that's got the $600,000 in debt is that
separate from your day jobs your normal
jobs so that's separate from our day
jobs my husband already Works 14 to 16
hour days six days a week and I do the
same thing on top of that on top of that
I like that's including me managing the
construction company um who's who's
working for you when you say manage the
construction company and you're working
14 to 16 hour days who are you managing
I am managing we have a group of I we
used to well I own one I used to have
about 15 people I cut it down to about
eight uh I weeded out the people that I
feel like instead of making me money it
I'm putting I'm putting money to okay so
you're like a general contractor
essentially I'm a general contractor yes
and you're and you're both working 14 to
16 hours a day correct is there any
collateral that you guys could sell as
part of this business equipment a real
estate yeah this is going to take a
decade to get out of at this rate well
um I I crunched the numbers and if my if
I put 12500 towards the business debt
and my dad puts 12500 towards the
business debt we'll be done in 28 months
your dad is half partner in all of this
well the the 651 half of it is his
however well I say his rhetoric I don't
want what's the correct word because at
the end of the day
it's under my name out of that probably
only 20% is under his name so no matter
what I have to pay but he's paying half
this is like a common core math question
Lizzy we got to sort this all out and
I'm excited for the baby but you're
right we got a mess on our hands it's
going to take some drastic choices for
probably 5 to 10 years to clean this up
but I hope it's faster than that we are
wishing you guys the best congrats on
the baby tell him today please don't let
him find out from this show this is the
ramsy show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything back by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 40% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Ken Coleman the number to call
is
5225 today's question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services there's never a good
time for replying is to break down but
Mr Appliance a neighborly brand can fix
them and help make sure they're running
properly go to neighbor.com Ramsey to
learn about upfront pricing from Mr
Appliance by the way I was called Mr
Appliance in my early college Years for
as much as you were a handyman is that
where that came from I just love these
names I'm jealous because I can't fix if
they called you like Mr
toolbag that one I think more
appropriate Mr Tool I get you all right
today's Applause from the studio the
booth guys like that glad you guys are
paying attention today that's good
today's question comes from Joseph in
Oregon I work in biotech as a data
scientist and my company is experiencing
Financial struggles with cash flow I was
just hired in this role about six months
ago and I'm wondering if it would be too
soon to begin looking for another job I
left the job that I had before this one
after one year because my manager was
extremely toxic and the company culture
wasn't good will two employment STS in
around a year be a red flag on my resume
let me just answer that one while we're
here yes uh is it something you can uh
overcome yes you can overcome that but
is it a red flag without question for
what it's worth I really enjoy my
current role team and Company with that
being said I just got married to my wife
two months ago so I want to make the
best financial decision for my family
moving forward would it be wise to begin
looking for another job or should I wait
to see what happens with the company in
a year um I think Joseph you've got a
you have a lack of stick tutiven that's
a madeup word it's a
quality uh it's called it's it's like a
little bit resiliency and a little bit
of patience mixed together that stick
tutiven and what I see here is a pattern
of I don't like what's going on right
now and I'm immediately going to pull
the escape hatch I'm out and I see that
a lot with younger
generations and there was a phenomenon
that happened in the marketplace in 2021
and 2022 when we saw 4 plus million
people a month leave their jobs for
about a year and a half it was
extraordinary never seen those kind of
numbers before they call it the great
resignation you may have heard heard
about that in the news
Well a year later we began to hear a
term called the Great regret where it
was millions of people who left during
the Great resignation the grass is
greener over here I can get more money
over here and that makes a lot of sense
on paper what happened is they made the
move and it wasn't the right move and
they began to regret leaving so I think
you might regret leaving this compy
compan right now I think it is other
than a slam dunk where you've got a a
better
gig um and you aren't having to walk
through all of the you know I was at
this job then I left and I was at this
job listen if your company is going
through financial struggles and cash
flow you need to be looking as a backup
plan anyway but just to immediately go
Oh I'm going to leave now I don't think
you have to do do I have some options in
this case George yes
but let's just see how it plays out a
little bit um he doesn't mention
anything in here that he feels like he's
going to be on the chopping block
nothing like that so if he was on the
line I'd ask has there actually been
layoffs what has been said from
leadership as far as the struggles so I
think I'd ask more questions but I think
when it comes to the employer you're
right Ken it's a red flag to the
employer they're going to ask and so you
better be ready to answer honestly and
tactfully hey what happened you had two
jobs in the last year well one was this
it wasn't a culture fit and this one
they had Financial struggles I'm not
going to so I left and that just makes
you look a little flighty here here's
the thing you know when we get on the
plane and they say all right we got to
go through the instructions and you know
if we have to make a water landing they
tell you all the things I think
professionally you got to have a plan
like what would happen you know it's
that kind of deal how would I exit if I
was forced to exit but in this case a
full-on search I don't think I would do
that in this case you know listen
there's a lot of people out there that
need to hear this if you go through a
storm in your work
place it's possible it's just a
storm doesn't mean like it's the new
normal and I think there's a big
difference and I think a lot of younger
people are susceptible to this listen
when a big storm comes through here's
what we know it blows through sun comes
up the next day and we move on and I
just think that many people would do
better to weather a storm or two or
three before they pick up and just move
on I think you get into a pattern of
moving Ming changing companies every
time something doesn't go your way it
could very quickly turn you into a
vagabond and I think that's dangerous
that's good wisdom appreciate the
question Joseph good stuff there let's
head to the phone lines pton awaits in
Chicago pton welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thank you good afternoon hey
how you doing how can we
help yeah I'm doing well um so I'm
fitting pretty well in regards like my
income and my debt my investments
however I have the opportunity to return
to graduate school and I'm not sure if
that's a good financial decision for me
considering I'll probably end up taking
out student loans to pay for it did you
say you have debt right
now uh no just my mortgage okay and what
are you going to graduate school
for that would be for a master's in
engineering and it's an MIT wow that's
impressive and I'm guessing you're in
engineering now full-time
correct yes okay what are you making
now making about $152,000 a year amazing
and would this help you I assume get a
big bump in pay are you looking to
switch like in a different field or
would you just excel in that field and
get promoted there yeah yeah um I would
hope it would like have a pay increase
um my larger hope though is I'm
currently an individual contributor and
it's not looking like I have a a clear
path my current company to become a
people leader of technical people which
is what you want so my hope is that
exactly yes um so my hope is that
following this graduate degree which is
a joint program between engineering and
business that MIT offers that more
easily find myself in that trajectory to
go to a supervisor of technical people
what would it cost for you uh to cash
flow
this probably around
$90,000
total yes yep so I'm actually currently
enrolled in the program I'm a semester
in my next semester and then a year
following that is what I would need to
pay for could you somehow save up 90
grand pause all investing and just stack
it up make an
152 um yeah so I would probably have to
sell some of my investments to that 90
grand outside of
retirement yes outside of retirement I
would do that
do you know why we're suggesting that
does that make before we tell you I'm
just curious when when someone hears us
say things like that does that make any
sense to you at all because if it
doesn't it's okay but I'm just
curious yeah I think I follow that train
of thought I also have the converse
train of thought that maybe it makes
more sense to leave that money there and
you know um ACR the gains in the mutual
funds that it's in right now for that
year instead of you know pulling it and
then feeding it again but okay so let's
fast forward because a short amount of
time right right so let's fast forward
to the end of the program and you're
90,000 in debt have you run the numbers
on what that payment is going to look
like when you got to start paying that
back no I have not I would I would fast
forward to the end of the line with
taking out a loan and and think about
what kind of money am I going to be
making okay do you have an idea about
what kind of money is realistic for you
with this
degree um I would love to be in the
neighborhood of $200,000 starting I know
you'd love to but is that
realistic yes for an engineering
supervisor great okay if you do your
homework on this George all I'm saying
is I like people to fast forward to the
end of this thing and go okay what's
going to look like even with that salary
paying 90 grand back oh yeah as opposed
to waiting using your advice of how much
do you have in Investments outside of
retirement
pyton I have about 38,000 so the 38 plus
your future income to save up you could
easily cash flow this in the next 12
months that plan excites me and how
quickly making 200k with no debt could
you restock 38,000 in an investment
account pretty quickly for sure yeah so
I would rather you move forward debt
free and it's going to give you more
options more peace and more freedom
every time you work that plan and uh I
didn't ask your age but it sounds like
you're young you got plenty of time on
your side you're clearly brilliant
you're going to retire a
multi-millionaire I just want you to be
debt free in the meantime and you're
going to do it I have full faith in you
congratulations call us back and let us
know how that path is uh going for you
thanks for the call this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman the
number to call is 88 25
5225 let's go to Atlanta up next Don
joins us there Don Merry Christmas
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you
thank you for having me what's going
on I am uh 53 years old and just started
the program about two months ago and I'm
because of where I'm at in my life with
um some of the debt needing to build an
emergency fund Etc I'm doing steps 2 3 4
and and
five at the same time that sounds like a
lot of things at the same time yes how's
that working for you well you know I
wouldn't say I would love to just focus
on two but I have a child who's in
college right now another one who is
going to college in the fall next year
so I'm real time making payments and I
did not have any savings for college why
do you feel like the burden is on
you uh
my parents paid for my college I feel it
necessary to do the
same well your story is different isn't
it you're not in a place to do
that are they going to instate schools
or community colleges is this the first
one is going to instate um the second
one will not be okay and that was a
decision that you both made or they just
made um we agreed um with that decision
myself s and the child are they
sophomores
freshman um I've got a freshman in
college I've got a senior in high school
and then I have a freshman in high
school okay so we got one on the way in
one that's in there and one that's got a
little bit of time correct okay and how
much debt do you
have I have
29 30,000 in debt it's made up of car at
21,000
and uh a interest free credit card at
9,000 until April
2025 okay what's your
income
225 that'll do hello awesome income so
what if let's just play this out if you
do it the Ramsay way and you focused on
one baby step at a time what do you
think that would do for you cuz you'd be
out of debt within a few few months and
you'd have the emergency fund a few
months later you'd be maxing out
retirement at that point a few months
later and then you'd still have time to
cash flow
College well the way I've worked it out
in the numbers
on I don't see how I can pay off that
debt in a few months that
30,000 why
not other bills um that have to be
covered and well College bills let's say
we put those aside and let's say we're
not putting anything in the emergency
fund let's say we're not investing at
all wouldn't that free up a whole bunch
of money to throw with the
debt right correct if I wasn't putting
anything in the emergency fund that
would definitely help me and so that's
why we tell people to work these baby
steps one at a time um I mean right now
you're doing Dawn's plan and I wish you
the best but I tell you with confidence
that our plan works when you work it the
way it's supposed to be worked which is
one at a time Focus intensity until you
get to Baby Steps
456 and making 225 you're going to be
there really fast this isn't a whole lot
of debt you're dealing with Don are you
buying what he
saying I am yes the concern is not
having anything in a uh emergency
fund concerned about emergencies okay
perfect so glad because I wanted you to
poke holes in in what he's saying cuz
George is right you should poke holes
but listen you have enough money in your
salary to be able to deal with most
emergencies and if you had to pause baby
step two which we tell people to do at
times if something big is there so that
you can cash flow it but you're going to
spend more time doing it your way than
you'll ever spend doing it our way
because you're just you're barely making
any progress trying to do all those
steps at the same time you can see that
right your money spread so thin but if
you do what George said said you're
going to knock that debt out really
quick and the next step is piling up
that emergency fund and the money that
you make the income you make you're
going to be able to do that very quickly
I mean you're bringing home 12 or 13,000
a month um it is my
uh my net is about
9,000 that's not tracking what I net how
you're you're taking 50%
home so I am
uh well that's I'm so sorry the net is
because I just gave you over one period
it's yeah it's
9,000 because of of the 41 K the
HSA so we're going to pause all of that
which is going to put a bunch of money
back
in that would take it probably to 12,000
I'm
assuming yes yeah and so so what's an
emergency that you would be really
scared of happening give us a realistic
emergency well the medical um any kind
medical um with my children well they'll
put you on a payment plan and you pay
when you can with medical see so give me
another
one I if I lost my job
okay but again we're not we don't use
emergency funds for job loss we tell
people look that's emergency funds are
for things like medical emergencies car
accident where you know you've got to
pay more on a deductible your HVAC
system goes out you don't want to be
living off of your emergency fund if you
can keep from it do you have to dip into
it in a job loss situation sure but the
idea is we want you to get back to work
anything and everything to not deplete
that here's the point I'm trying to make
I want you to think of your biggest
scariest emergency monster and I'm
telling you with your income you should
be able to handle it isn't that fair
George am I being am I being too
aggressive there so don if you look at
your barebones expenses what is that
that up to to just cover food utility
shelter Transportation Insurance yeah um
probably 6K a month I could just if I
got rid of you know some other things
some of the luxuries yeah so that leaves
potentially another six that you could
start throwing at this debt and so
you're really smart this is easy math in
5 months paying 6K you're completely
debt free in five months so even though
I because I should I feel like I need to
be maxing out that 41k at 15% because of
my I don't have much time to catch up at
this point in my life you don't have
time to keep playing this game where
you're treading water imagine making 225
with no payments in the world and now
you're maxing out every retirement
account known to man for the next 10
years with catchup contributions you're
going to be okay that's right okay so
you're not losing ground Dawn I I tell
you all this I to trust the process I
know it's hard especially when you're in
your 50s and it's harder to change
habits and behavior and look at things a
different way but I have met people who
have been 60 and 70 and they've just
committed themselves to this plan and it
has worked and they're able to retire
with dignity and for sure you're going
to be able to do that with your amazing
income if I had
21 um or 19,000 in some stock um not
retirement would you
recommend just getting rid of that and
putting that towards the debt yep I'd
sell it and I'd be aware of the tax
implication that may be there when you
sell it on the gains but I did the same
thing Don to pay off the rest of my debt
okay yeah there's no tax implications
because the company took care of the
taxes wonderful nice how much could you
make on that sale you said it's 19 yeah
right now it's it's um the value of it's
19 do you understand that just means
you're debt free like a month or two
from now it's amazing in my brain I've
been thinking of that as e helping with
emergency if there was an emergency what
if we saidar mentality you're doing
great what if we said your debt was an
emergency you need to get that out how
about that little mindset that's a way
to look at
it um good job I'd say being 53 without
a full emergency fund while playing with
debt that is the true emergency and
that's why these baby steps are all
about intensity for a short season and
so what we're asking here is Don for 6
to 8 months you're going to be focused
on this
then we can start looking at investing
again and helping the kids cash flow
this but the kids are going to be all
right they have an awesome Mom they're
able to work part-time they're able to
hustle and get scholarships and grants
and choose a different school and take a
gap year you got to put your own mask on
First and that's you working the baby
steps on your own right now but we have
full faith you're going to get there I'm
going to gift you one year of every
dollar premium and Financial Peace
University to help walk with you and
encourage you along the way so hang on
the line we'll get S sell the stock do
it this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey show this is
a show for you America to help you take
the right next step with your life your
work your money give us a call atle
88255 225 I'm George Campbell joined by
Ken Coleman this hour let's go to the
phones to DC Ryan joins us there Ryan
what's going going on hey guys thanks
for taking my call
absolutely hey so I wanted to get you
some advice and some help from you guys
uh something we're struggling with um me
and my wife are wondering how we can
continue um tackling baby step two um
while I support her in wanting to stay
home with the kids um and she's going to
uh you know transition into a part-time
job which uh you know pretty much cuts
her salary in
half okay what's the current
income uh So currently right now uh with
no overtime for me uh I'm making about
4,000 a month and then uh she's making
4,900 okay and she's wanting to go
part-time or is she already done that
she's she will be going part-time we
have uh baby number two on the way um so
he's due in February um she she will get
some um some paid leave with her with
her job to help take care of the baby
and so she's going to attempt to go back
to work after that um but we know it's
it's you know kind of not really going
to work out so come June July is when
she's going to transition into um
staying home with the boys and and
working parttime and and do she have a
plan for that because you said she like
you okay what's she gonna be making yeah
yeah uh she's GNA make probably about um
2,000 um a month uh she'll be working
for uh her mom's travel agent company
okay so you posed it as we're we're
we're struggling we're having some
challenges what exactly are you wanting
us to jump into on this the budgeting
side of this or is this a marital
relationship
conversation oh no no this is a this is
a budgeting uh budgeting conversation so
we downloaded the every dollar app back
in um actually November 1st so we've
been at it about a month um we've gone
from $68,000 in debt down to 109 um you
know I've followed those steps uh you
know took the savings down um which was
a gut check um but you know with my job
you know I travel a lot and I can get
you know copious amounts of overtime so
it does help and so you really just
trying to knock down the debt hole that
I got us in and um before this happens
before we lose the if it's even possible
how long did it take to get that debt
knocked out 168 to
109 one month I am because took the we
did yeah yes sir we took the savings I
sold stock um you know the the little
you know savings we had for um uh right
you know right before the baby's coming
you know we just kind of went all in and
yeah now we're now we're just tackling
it pretty much any overtime I get over
that um you know 2,000 per paycheck is
going directly to to debt so is that net
income that you shared with
me yes sir it is okay all right so
you're you bring home about 50k net and
she's bringing home about 60k
net yes sir but overall it'll go down to
72 if this all works
out yeah yeah okay so it's going to slow
down your debt payoff dramatically with
her you know taking a pause and then go
part-time and so that's a consequence
you know of you guys deciding hey she's
going to stay home it means the debt may
take you know 6 months longer than we
wanted it to yeah that was me wondering
if that was okay you know because we had
this you know this whole plan and you
know if God's wanting her to stay home
and she feels like that's what she wants
to do I'm I'm going to make it happen if
I got to pick up all the overtime I need
well you would need to dramatically
increase your income because here's the
thing average it takes people 18 to 24
months to pay off Consumer Debt and
looking at these numbers you still have
109 to pay off and I don't know how much
able to throw at the debt every month
but you know let's say how much could
you think you can do now once she goes
part time typically with with the
overtime I'm typically bringing home um
close to 5,000 per uh per pay per
paycheck but how much can you throw at
debt um our expenses are
only uh let's see I'm looking at it here
uh
5200 per month
only you're bringing home five and your
expenses are 52 you're about to broke my
man yep no no no 50 um the the 5,000 per
paycheck if I'm doing if I'm doing OT so
the monthly expenses are to 5,000 and
then the is that sustainable for the
next 12 months for you to do
overtime unfortunately in my job it's uh
you can't avoid the overtime with the
government okay well I would devise a
plan to where you can knock out $109,000
in about two
years okay whatever ever that looks like
with her working part-time you working
overtime if it's going to take four or
five years to knock this out this is a
bad plan it's just too long George I'm
wondering is there any lifestyle change
you guys can
make so we've cut you this will make you
even even more sick we've cut uh $2,000
out of the budget worth of those those
extra expenses you know the the
subscriptions the your daily coffee
meals the you know nights out eating um
and we've gone you know pretty much
completely to we eat at home and that's
it you shaved off 25 Grand a year right
what's the9 made up of what kind of debt
is
that H that was uh that's that's me um
she I mean she her student loans um that
she has doesn't account for anything
that's the well it accounts for some
15,500 um and then the other um you know
5,000 the last credit card we actually I
got to take that off cuz we just paid
that today 5,7
what's the chunk what's the big one the
big one is a deck um when when we bought
our house we finan the deck and that was
my fault and yeah she yeah we'll leave
it at that you guys got cars car loans
um yeah uh she has she has one car I do
not I get one for work okay what's left
on her car loan on it oh no loan okay no
sir no all right so real quick George I
want to talk about his income because I
hear the young man I can hear the heavy
breathing in I mean I feel for you man
and you're a good dude um one thing we
haven't talked about in this
conversation is your ability to increase
your income and I don't mean overtime
what do you do for the government or
what kind of work are you in um I work
for Homeland Security okay is that the
long-term play for
you so that that's kind of the second
part to it I didn't know if we'd have
time to get into it I am looking at
changing to a different position um I'm
not going to do that until we are debt
free um because it is a salary drop for
the first year um but it's it's less
time away in these um you know kind of
not so good areas and more time home all
right but what okay and I think that's
great I love that part but what's the
long-term potential of this job that you
would take a hit in the first year
what's it look like is there a ladder
for financial growth there there is yes
sir move up every year on the oh it'll
it's it's a good chunk I'd have to have
done the scale in front of me but it's
the typical you know GS scale um for the
government so after three years I'm back
to 125 a year all right so listen if I
could play older brother really quick
okay yeah I that's another government
job and I'm not anti-government jobs
every time I say something like this on
the Ramy show people come after me like
you're anti-government yeah I am
anti-government because I'm a
conservative and I think people should
be free to live how they want to there's
the commercial but you're not going to
have as much Financial potential working
for the government as you could doing
similar work in the private sector
that's what I'm trying to get at my
friend you making 100,000 $120
$150,000 doing similar work in the
private sector I believe is
realistic I think you should check it
out but just limiting yourself to G3 and
then after a couple more years of good
service Uncle Sam lets me move up the
ladder you're just really limited
financially yes or
no yes yeah you are well my friend let's
do both let's get out of debt and grow
professionally how about that yes sir
how about we go get a fat raise in the
next six
months instead of taking a step back in
a government job I'm challenging you to
think about it yes sir Ryan the last
part of this is you guys are in stor
mode right now uh until baby and mom are
home safe from the hospital which means
we're going to pause the debt payoff
make minimum payments and stack up as
much cash as you can over the next three
3 months and then once mom and baby are
home and healthy let's continue and
throw that all that at the debt so that
will help you as well give you some
peace as you step into this new phase
we're excited for you man that puts this
hour of the ramsy show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Ken Coleman all the
guys and gals in the booth keeping the
show afloat and you America we'll be
back before you know
[Music]
it
m live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George Campell joined by my colleague
Ken colan and we're here to serve you
America the number to call is
8825 5225 and I say America but we've
been getting a lot more uh International
these days k a lot of listeners calling
in from all over the you got to be
careful you just offended the globe
George just like
you know you got to we're we are very
inclusive when it comes to advice about
your money your work and your
relationships that's right regardless of
where you live come one come all the
principles apply get out of debt stay
out of debt have an emergency fund build
wealth for the future and you're going
to be okay that works whether you're in
uh Australia or the United States you
know what we should do this summer we
should throw a shrimp on the barbie I
think we should for our friend Luke who
joins us in Brisbane Australia is that
how you say it is it Brisbane did I get
that that right Luke I'm trying to
be better yeah that's it that's it it's
uh Brisbane good morning it's currently
just after 7 a.m. Saturday morning I
wish I talked like you Luke I got to
tell you I really like I'm listening to
an Australian weatherman I do I'm going
to ask you extra questions because I
want to hear you talk northeasterly
winds coming from the south no worries
see I need to say from the south they're
northeasterly we'll get it later Luke
how welcome from
Australia okay thank you very much
gentlemen I love what you two do and I
love what Dave does and all the team
that does um I've been listening to the
show now for about 3 or four months and
um I'm 21 so I'm only really just kind
of getting into the whole world Big Wide
World of money and working and all of
that full time um I've been in a bit of
a pickled situation at the moment um
I've just broken up out of a near
two-year relationship and that's put me
in a bit of a struggle um but one thing
I've learned from that as you know the
only way you can move is forward and um
I basically just want to tackle the one
and only debt I have and um get some
basically just some life advice on where
to go from there how to use my money
just some General Life advice for
growing up too well I got to ask you
then did you dump or were you
dumped I was dumbed oh man I I was
worried about that I'm sorry about that
how long ago did that happen
um a couple of weeks now all right
listen man you're going to be okay
you'll find Love Again Luke yeah we've
all been there man yeah I've I got
dumped pretty hard in college did you
get dumped oh 100% yeah yeah so
hey you're you're in good company Luke
so what's the One debt you
have all right so to make it easier for
you guys I've converted all my things
that I think I would mention I've
converted all that from Australian
dollars to US dollar one and only debt
the one and only debt I have is a really
stupid car
loan and um I am currently owing about
$20,000 on that okay what's your income
USD uh uh USD my income is uh at ranges
it's between 53 and 55,000 what do you
do I am a long-distance truck driver oh
all right cool cool okay so um I'm
looking at doing a once um I'm looking
at doing a career change and then moving
internationally because don't get me
wrong Australia is all well and good and
it's really cool here and you know there
are some lovely people here I don't know
I just don't feel like it's for me in
the long run oh so what uh paint that
picture for us what are you doing and
where are you
living all right so I live in Brisbane
um I've got my debt and I'm looking at
getting rid of that and um next year I
have enrolled to go to Aviation college
and go get my commercial pilot's license
so that's the career change I wanted to
do and I wanted to be a pilot since I
was like 12 13 years old good for you
are you going to be able to cash flow
that I am not unfortunately how much
ises it how much does it cost it's very
pricey here in the US what is it in in
Australia all right so to get my
commercial license plus my multi-engine
rating which will allow me to fly
aircraft with two or more engines and
also getting my instrument rating so I
can um which is a probably a great
necessity of flying commercially in the
long run all of that total is up to
about
$108,000 yeah yeah that sounds about
right that checks out well we don't want
you going into debt for this Luke you
got to know that
right yeah how the way um I don't
necessarily know how it works over there
in the US I know I've I keep hearing a
lot of callers calling and say they have
um private student loan debt from like
Sally ma or something and um I don't
necessarily know know much more than
that I don't know if you can get it like
I know you can get scholarships because
you can get scholarships as well over
here um but the way that I'm looking at
doing it is um getting it through the
government and then paying it back
through taxes so none of it comes out of
my paycheck however when I go to do my
tax return every year um because I don't
know how it works over there but in
every um pay slip I get um taxes come
out of my pay automatically so don't
have to worry about um paying my tax at
at the end of every Financial year I do
a tax return still and correct yeah if
you're a W2 employee here meaning your
your employer is going to pay that
portion out it'll get deducted and paid
to the government
automatically yes and that that's
standard over here unless you run your
own business that's standard over you're
saying they add your student loan
payment into your taxes
essentially yeah you pay it off through
the taxes that you pay so it's
essentially still a payment you're just
making it sort of all at once at the end
of the year through your tax return so
you might owe $10,000 on your tax
return yeah and instead of um me getting
anything back on my tax return or all of
that which I would be eligible to
receive back um all of that goes into
paying for what would be my student loan
I'm confused you're saying there would
never be a bill that you would owe what
if you don't get money back
no
that I unaware of but
um because here in America you don't
always get a refund I've owed many years
and you got to pay that and so I imagine
it's not free this loan isn't free so I
don't want you to think that there's
some well it's all paid taxes no way no
way um but you know I get like a tax
refund like it's um pretty Mo most
people typically get a tax refund every
year um I have always gotten a tax
refund every year over here I know um
there's been like stories where people
have you know worked a standard 9 to-5
job and then for some reason they owe
10,000 to the tax office but I've never
managed to Grapple my head around that
well regardless of how it works there we
want you to cash flow this and if that
means you got to move slower you got to
increase your income or you got to sell
this car in order to cash flow this
that's the plan cuz taking on over 100
Grand in debt is not going to make you a
better pilot and it's going to cause
more stress when you get
there yeah which is why was thinking as
well whether I go through with it or
whether I just delay it just do it at
the speed of cash delay I mean so what
would it take for you to save
$25,000 a year I'm being aggressive
there but that get you
$100,000 okay what would it take a young
guy like you you're driving a truck well
can you sell $25,000 a year in four
years you got the money and now there's
no stopping and you before you know it
you're up flying the friendly Skies you
know flying to Nashville coming to see
us hey you know taking us for a ride uh
we'll take you for a shrimp on the
barbie you do it debt free shrimp on the
barbie free from me ooh how about that
Outback where we taking him yeah we'll
take him now back of course where else
would I take an Australia in the United
States onion Onion Man Luke thanks for
the call it was a pleasure speaking with
you this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell join joined by Ken
Coleman hey if you like the show do us a
favor and it's a free favor if that's
any consolation please consider
subscribing to the show wherever you're
listening or hit the follow button leave
a review wherever you're listening and
share with a friend there's a lot of
little buttons you can click to share
you can just send a link if you're
watching on YouTube um tell them just
verbally go check out the show wherever
they listen to podcast or get their
shows that means the world to us you
guys are our marketing plan and you do
such a great job and we're so grateful
for the spreading the word all right
let's get to it Jacob is in Charlotte up
next Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thanks for having me absolutely
so I just got hit with a with a pretty
significant amount of debt that me and
my wife we not expecting to have um her
parents were unaware that they were
taking out student loans I'm not sure
how that happened but we just got hit
with an extra
$15,000 for her undergrad on top of her
$15,000 for her Masters that we already
knew about um and so I'm trying to
figure out the best way to attack this
what I need to sell what I need to keep
in order to pay that off man I'm sorry
to hear that so it sounds like there was
a giant lack of communication with how
the parents were quote unquote paying
for college and she thought well they've
got it taken care of little did she know
they were taking out loans in her name
they yeah I think they thought they had
had it taken care of too um and then we
just are on the unfortunate end of that
all right well it's up to you guys now
it's all in her name
right uh yeah it is these weren't like
Parent Plus Loans that were
cosigned uh I think her dad's co-signed
on it but they made it clear they're not
going to help okay cool cool cool well
what's your household income
now so right now we make a combined
about
110,000 um we own a couple rental houses
and we net about another 15,000 with
those um so it's a little over
120,000 okay and is this all of the debt
the Consumer Debt these two student
loans so no she she's got a car loan as
well and that's about
177,000 okay and then you have a bunch
of
mortgages yeah so we've got the two
rental houses and then we've got the
house that we live in so we have three
mortgages but um those are they're
pretty well taken care of on their own
as it
stands for now on paper but man you got
a lot of risk in your life as a young
couple yeah how old are you
too we're about 25 all right well the
good news is making 120 knocking out you
know 47,000 in debt is not a huge math
equation the question is how little can
you live on and how much can you throw
at the debt to knock this out as quickly
as possible and you said you're willing
to to sell some stuff what do you have
that you can
sell well I was thinking about my first
thought is you know if we sell the house
that we live in um we would we would net
after taxes a little over 50,000 so that
would knock out the debt pretty quickly
but then that would leave us in the
position to have to rent or use our um
you know savings account to buy another
house I'd rather you sell a rental
before you sell yeah place you
sleep the only thing about that is the
rental houses have a 2.7% and
3.2% goodness we're going to argue about
interest rates why why do you think that
changes the
equation because he'll never get a 2.7
interest rate again I know I was wanting
him to say it I think it's I think it's
because the the cash flow on those
houses are just so good that I don't
want to those up okay let's run through
it hold on hold on hold on you just told
me you're you're netting 15K a year it's
not much that's amazing cash flow to
you I mean as a 25y old no you make 110
dude you make way more money than that
you know what 15,000 divided by 12 is
it's not very much a month that is not
amazing cash well that's that's the
profit after taxes after the mortgages
are paid H still you're acting like
$15,000 is a lot of money that is not a
lot of money you could make that in a
side hustle easy yeah so I just don't
want you to get star eyed and I
understand I'm not trying to beat up on
you we're having some fun but man people
are just get so stuck on these interest
rates instead of thinking about a bigger
picture which is how do we live with no
debt and our greatest wealth building
tool back in our life our income instead
of hey what's the spread on this and
what's the interest rate and I can make
more if I invest this and uh if you can
figure that out sooner rather than later
cuz you're 25 you got lots of time on
your hands to let compound growth and
wise decisions guide you to some big
wealth but right now the truth is you
guys can pay off this debt you're
looking for the shortcut of selling your
own house to do that you don't need to
what you need to do is sacrifice and
have some Behavior
change well should we should we cut into
our you know saving like our personal
savings account to pay off some of it
and then well now you need emergency
funds for these two rental properties
don't
you yeah so we can't necessarily just
deplete our savings because you guys
have you know this has some consequence
when you get rental properties and
that's you have risk and you got to be
ready to cover those what I don't think
you see is J is Jacob is you're you're
overleveraged right now and George is
going you guys make enough money to pay
this off and your first response was
should we cut into our savings it's like
you're not getting it and I'm not being
tough on you I'm just saying you have
the income you have the ability to pay
the 40 what is it
47,000 uh off pretty quickly with some
hustle even if you don't agree with this
on the rental properties you got
yourself in a lot of risk you don't have
any margin right now and you're
celebrating $115,000 being the the
kickoff of the those rental properties
so something's got to
change so you have to decide what do you
want to change but paying off
$47,000 at the income that you guys have
is not hard to do without selling any
property yeah you don't have to sell
anything just get hustled put pay it off
cut
expenses okay make some more money look
at it this way you throw $5,000 at the
debt it's gone in 10 months
correct yeah do you have $5,000 of
margin to throw at the debt per month
um yeah I think I mean I think we could
make that work it's just yeah I just I
love saving money but right now we need
to but you also called us saying dude
I'm overwhelmed right now we just found
out we have an extra 15,000 of debt so
to tell me that this debt isn't weighing
on you whether it's the mortgages of the
Consumer Debt would be a lie and so I'm
just trying to get you to look at the
reality of it going we can solve this
pretty quickly either with our income or
by selling one of these properties and
we're going to lose our precious cash
flow which will knock it I'm guessing in
half right yeah y but you'll be back if
you do this a different way or the right
way you'll be back to being a Real
Estate Mogul paying cash for properties
with some sweet cash flow y but right
now you guys are super young over
leverag like Ken mentioned and trying to
figure out some kind of loophole to get
out of this debt but you're the solution
you're income and Jacob I want to
challenge something you just said
because I do think it's the way you're
thinking about all of this you're a
smart guy hard worker you're going to be
successful no we're not worried about
you but you said I just love saving
money how can you love saving money when
you're when you when you're over lever
and you're giving your money away to
other people so I don't think that
you're a contrarian but I'm just trying
to point out that that's what I'm
hearing the audience is hearing you're
going I just love saving money that's
why I don't want to pay off my debt does
that make any sense when you hear back
yeah I just I think when when I think
about it I love saving money so that I
can and invest it in other places rather
than spend it on consumer things right
but my point still holds the best way
for you to save money is to eliminate
debt yeah add up those payments andg if
you could invest all of those payments
instead look at what that would turn
into over the next 35 years of your life
and that will cause you to get out of
debt real quick yep margin my friend
margin like really think about personal
financial margin not the margin that
they talk about Wall Street movies and
Tik toks and all this I mean real
Financial margin for you you got to
understand that concept when you get
that that's freedom gamechanging freedom
you guys got kids
Jacob no not yet as soon as you do
you're going to be thankful that you got
no payments cuz go back and listen to
some of the calls we've taken where
people are going we have our second kid
on the way but we have all this debt and
I want her to stay home but it's really
hard for us right now man you're too
successful and smart to ever deal with
that problem and so this is very
solvable but there's only two options
and they both require sacrifice and
behavior change so pick your poison I
got three teenagers they're very
expensive I can't get them out of the
house fast enough right now I'm kidding
I'm kidding kids your son Ty could be on
man versus food that guy could down a
ribey pretty quick I'm just telling you
the amount of food I go through is
insane it would frighten you young
parents be ready have some Financial
Peace that's always the best plan of
attack this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by my good friend
Ken Coleman hey the Ramsey Christ
Christmas Cash giveaway is going on
right now you could win one of our $500
weekly prizes or the grand prize of
$5,000 just go to ramseys solutions.com
SLG giveaway you can enter every day to
increase your chances of winning and
while you're there be sure to check out
our $12 sale on some of our bestselling
books tools and products at ramsy
solutions.com
sstore Ryan joins us up next in New York
Ryan what's going on hi hi hi George and
Ken good afternoon good afternoon my
question my question is is I have an
$8,000 bill that just came up and it
needs to be paid uh by the end of the
year it's a u basically a look back
policy that needs to be uh paid for
liability um so what I'm trying to out
could I just simply take the money out
of my money market account I have about
$10,000 in a money market account which
I I kind of consider to be my emergency
fund which has dwindled down over the
years and it's down to about 10,000 or
would I be better off decreasing my my
401k contributions or reduce the amount
that I'm paying extra on my mortgage
each month and the other option is is I
have an open
$25,000 uh money um Equity or uh home
equity that I could take at 8% to cover
that expense so we're going to go into
debt to pay off debt that doesn't TR
exactly exactly let's not do that one I
would just if the only cash you have is
that 10K liquid to your name is that
what you're telling me well yeah as far
as something I could take out with any
penalties I mean it's basically just a
money market account that spendable cash
okay yeah I would use that but you
immediately need to restock that and get
it to a full emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses okay is that the
only debt you have currently other than
your house no I just my yeah my home I
have that down to under
150,000 um so that's something that I'm
hoping to pay off within the next couple
of years but yeah no other significant
debt beyond that just a typical credit
cards that come in but I always pay them
in full every month I'd cut those cards
up man they have not been serving you up
to this point and they will not in the
future so that's going to be your best
bet I've never paid any interest on them
I just use them for groceries and gas
and things like that well you can never
pay a diamond interest and still retire
broke that's America for you and that's
where people are at and so it's it's not
you know I'm proud of you I'd rather you
never pay a diamond interest and pay
thousands but it's not a wealth building
tool and uh it just makes credit card
companies rich and you know so so
without a credit card what are people
doing as far as paying for their you
know your typical expenses with gasoline
and groceries and Amazon I mean how can
you live without a credit card at all
well I've done it for a decade now and
lived to tell the tale and here's how I
do it I use a debit card you can use if
you're worried about privacy and that
kind of thing you can use a website
called privacy.com to create virtual
debit cards that you can then they're
it's tied to your account but it's a
virtual debit card number that if was
stolen you'd be fine U so that's one
thing and if your debit card has a Visa
or MasterCard logo on it then you have
their zero liability policy with your
debit card yeah and so you're fine uh
but as far as the pay that down get the
emergency fund back up to where it needs
to go then begin investing 15% if you're
not already are you there or you not
investing that much in what in which
account your retirement accounts oh the
retirement I've been maxing it for
couple of decades now oh good okay yeah
no i' I've maxed that's my one priority
is to always make sure I'm maximizing my
401k every month wonderful so beyond
your 15% I assume you have a great
income if you're doing that um don't
okay you know we don't have crazy
expenses I have no need to travel you
know that kind of thing we uh pretty
much just have a list of priorities and
my priority is to obviously be
comfortable in
retirement and having no debt and so
your next your next thing to solve there
is getting rid of that mortgage so
beyond investing I'd start attacking
that mortgage uh once we have the
emergency fund once this Deb's paid off
and so that will set you on the path so
as far as my my second option what I
mentioned possibly decreasing those 401
contribution or maybe not paying the
extra $500 a month on the mortgage would
you I would stop paying extra on the
mortgage for now to restock the
emergency fund but right now I would
instantly just get rid of this bill with
that cash that you have on hand and
restock it it's not worth pausing
investing when you're this is a very
quick temporary thing yep okay but I
would pause the the mortgage payment
until you have that six months saved in
expenses that's going to give you some
great peace as you head into retirement
and it will allow you to never have to
go back into debt again and not have to
worry about these ankle biters that come
up so thank you for the call Ryan
appreciate it man Aiden is up next in
Dallas Texas what is happening
Aiden yes sir so I am 15 I have around
25,000 in cash and 10,000 in equity and
I'm not sure where to go from here wow
15 how'd you get the
cash so I've started with $400 and since
I was about 12 and I've just had this
thing for dirt bikes and then ever since
I bought my first dirt bike for $400
I've been kind of flipping them as of
now and now I have 25,000 from flipping
dirt bikes flipping dirt bikes give me a
quick rundown on how much you're
spending and then and then how much it
takes to fix them and then flip them
what's the average what would you
say so right now I'm averaging around
two to1 to $2,000 in each flip my most
recent one was actually I made so I
spent
$5,400 and I made 7,000 from it so nice
I sold it for 12,000 that a boy
so phenomenal wow George how about go
I'm very impressed so you you have this
entrepreneur bug in you it sounds like
you may not go the traditional route
since considering you made 25k at
15 yes it how many years did this take
like you've been doing this for a while
so yes sir four years it's picked up
this year mainly the last three months
this is honestly when I've made the most
cuz I've averaged around 2 to 3,000 and
then I finally got into it like mainly
I'm like okay I really want to do this
and now I'm making I mean pretty good
profit now I have 25,000 plus four dirt
bikes right now yes sir fantastic and
what's your equity and you said you had
10K Equity is that in the bikes yes sir
okay well you're asking us what should I
do with this money that's sitting in the
account yes sir well for starters I
would just keep it in a high yield
savings account for now so that it can
grow at a you know a decent rate for you
four 5% while you decide what's next now
at 15 truthfully you got no clue what's
going what the next 10 years looks like
but one of the keys is to stay debt
free yes sir and so if you can continue
cash you know buying these in cash and
flipping them that's going to be your
best bet but what does the next you know
five years look like for Aiden does he
want to be flipping dirt bikes at 2025
or are you want to go to college and get
into a career
field yes sir so what I'm going to want
to do U my brother's uh went into the
air force I don't know if I want to
follow him or if I just want to kind of
chill and like do this as like a little
side hobby but what do you want to do
with your life that's my
question yes sir so that's a big one
like I don't know yet yeah you're 15
you're 15 Uncle George is being very
intense right now that's so int a tough
one to I'm just wondering cuz he could
follow path he could still be selling
dirt bikes at 5050 I don't know I'm just
wondering he loves this but it's not the
dirt bikes itself necessarily so let me
pull it back a little bit really quick
uh are are Mom and Dad buying you a car
do you have to buy a car um yes they're
they are buying you a car yes sir all
right so you don't need you don't need
the money for a car I can tell you don't
need money for girls or uh spending cash
you're fine all right so the savings
account so what's next it would be a
college or some type of a trade school
or some type of training at at 15 you
just don't know and you don't need to
know yet um but I just got a sneaky
suspicion you're going to be an
entrepreneur my friend and please don't
let anybody talk you into college unless
it is the only way or the best way to do
something because you're already showing
us what the American dream is there's
folks with a business degree that don't
know what you know they can't make the
money you're making if you stuck them
out there in the on on the Main Street
and said figure it out they couldn't do
what you're doing and I can just tell
you that's the truth so
I think George is Right does he invest a
little bit a little bit I would uh open
a Roth IRA if I were you you got earned
income I
would so that's one one way to do it I'd
Max one of those out for the year in 45
years from now you're going to call back
and say dude I'm a millionaire just
because of that account alone so that's
it invest that Roth and then save save
save save save the more you save the
more options you have young man yeah if
you can have $100,000 at 22 and or you
could pay cash for your first home I
mean these are the goals that we all
have wish I go back in time and become
Aiden I wouldn't push him to college at
all I'd say go find out how to flip
something else that guy's going to be a
multi-millionaire thanks for the call
Aiden this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Hebrews
13:16 but do not forget to do good and
to share for with such sacrifices God is
well pleased
Charles Spurgeon once said deciding what
not to do is as important as deciding
what to do wise words Charles Spurgeon
you know who that is oh yeah all right
many he called it the prince of
preachers oh yeah I like that I mean him
and CS Lewis are up there the alltime
greats CS Lewis not a preacher well I
mean as far as the writing goes their
writing is masterful all right that
works thank you Ken it's fun there's
some you know I'm a technical I can't
can't help myself on the history stuff I
got too nerdy well you're a preachers
kid but I get what you're saying you
were saying overall voices of the faith
you could beat me in Sword drills that's
for sure boy couldn't I all right let's
get to the phones Leslie is up next in
Birmingham Alabama Leslie what's going
on with you oh did I screw it up there
we go
Leslie Hi how are y'all thank You' all
so much for taking my call sure how can
we help um yes so um really like it's
it's just been difficult over the last
few years to try to figure out the right
mindset around this and I know I'm
messing up because I'm going into Deb so
I'm trying to get a hold of that but um
and I actually called in a few weeks ago
so Ken may remember me but um basically
my son has some some health conditions
and it's it's just hard to know the
right balance between being Frugal and
doing things that are good for his
health like for example you know there's
the whole idea of red Dy linked to hyper
activity so okay remove red dyes from
food that means you're going to spend a
little more in some cases just little
things like that um you know asthma get
a waterproof mattress cover that kind of
thing little things like that it's just
how you deal with the anxiety and how
you balance quality of life for your kid
and being Frugal and it's just I can't
it's hard to figure out what's essential
and what's not because you want the best
for your child but you also don't want
to be in debt you know so yeah well let
me let me step back then and I
understand this need as a parent I
really do um because you go you read an
article this day you read an article the
next day you see something on Instagram
it's like this is good this is good and
you go I just want to give my boy the
best I want to give him the best shot
and it's G to wear you out and and you
know you can get a different opinion on
on something different every day so for
instance we all see this in the news one
day bacon will kill you the next day
bacon is the key to long life who really
knows I don't know I always stay in the
middle cuz I just keep eating bacon so
I'm in good I'm in good shape regardless
cuz if that's how I die it's a good way
to go eating a piece of bacon now I got
distracted um the question I have for
you as a mom is are you doing the best
you can with what the doctors are saying
that you need to be doing and providing
him that
care I feel that I am it's really just
trying to go trying to go above and
beyond you advantage of the latest
research and all that I know but my
point is I think there's a point where
you have to go I'm doing the best I can
and what we're doing is enough you are
enough you're doing what the doctors
have said at some point you you you
can't live in fear you got to live with
faith and you got to move forward and I
and I totally understand where you're
coming from but you can drive yourself
crazy so Leslie let's get tactical what
is causing you to go into
debt um
well it it's you know I mean there's car
repairs that I didn't you know have any
savings for that's kind of piled up um
on credit cards and then um moving
expenses uh but then a big part of it is
just just monthly you know expenses that
I can't afford you know I had a lot
lower income so your better job which is
great but it's 70 but I have a lot of
debt so what what kind of debt do you
have uh 75 in loans and 25 in credit
cards but how much of that credit card
debt is these sheets this just wondering
how much is your son versus just life
has hit you because I don't want you to
confuse the
two yes I've actually been wondering
that too I I should probably go and I
mean I don't know go and analyze the
accounts and see what all I feel like at
least half of it though is buying really
good quality food air filters
supplements things like that it is it is
that's why you started the call that way
that's what's going on now that we we
found a problem George she doesn't
actually know well that's where the
budget's going to come into play and did
we gift you every dollar last time you
spoke to Ken um no but I I actually do
have a budgeting app that I'm trying out
uh it's not every dollar but I'm giving
why out a shot but I might you know go
to every
doll I'm going to give you every dollar
premium because it's going to come with
all the sweet sweet features why did so
much simpler why did I who was I who was
I on with les you get In the Heat of the
Moment who was Ken on with when you
spoke
let's see it was um um it was Rachel and
me get clear assessment oh I gave you
that it was more for the career side I
gave you for the work side but we should
have given you the budget out okay I
want to make sure it's probably Rachel's
fault she's not as giving as I am so I
mean I think that's probably her fault
I'm kidding folks it's a joke well
Leslie once we get off the line hang on
Skyler will gift you that every dollar
Premium app per year but here's what
you're going to do you're going to list
out every single expense and you're
going to do an audit this is not just
what I wanted to be you're going to
match it to reality of what um you know
what things are actually costing you so
part of that is looking at your bank
statement and going oh my gosh I spent
$1,200 on food and oh I forgot that
subscription we were still paying for
and so there's things that we can cut
back on that that's going to help but
the glaring issue here is the $100,000
in Consumer Debt not the fact that we
have to buy organic
groceries and so part of this is
truthfully we got to cut up the credit
card it's become a plastic crutch that
is not serving you um and you know if
push comes to shove how would you cover
expenses if you didn't have the credit
card you would cut back in another areas
or you'd go make more money
right yes and I've actually just gotten
on a plan that's gonna with a nonprofit
in the credit cards are closed and it's
a much lower interest rate so I just got
to pay no no this sounds like a scam
Leslie did you get in touch with one of
these like debt relief
companies no no it's a nonprofit it was
actually recommended to me by Chase and
they are it doesn't it doesn't ruin your
credit or anything by Chase the credit
card company hold on hold on you thought
a credit card company existed to serve
you in any way shape or form to help you
get out of
debt well listen to that just listen
back to what you just
said they they don't make any late
payments it doesn't mess up your credit
at
all I just I'm very concerned about what
this program is and I would go read the
fine print to figure out how you got
screwed because I'm almost positive that
it's not going to help you
but the key here is I want you out of
this credit card debt you may prove me
wrong but I've just never seen one of
these programs that actually helps
people get out of debt any faster than
your own the solution is Leslie and her
income and her behavior change not some
gift from Chase
Bank so yeah it it's a nonprofit but
yeah well there okay here's the deal
what George is saying is right I want
you focused on the budget because you
got to know how much of your expenses
are going to doing everything you can
for your for your little guy and then
you've got to be able to start walking
through that with your doctor and going
we've done the best with we what we have
to know and what they're going to keep
doing and treating him that way you
can't pay for every Theory or every hack
or whatever to make his life you just
can't you're you're limiting and and if
you're limited he's limited if you're
stressed he's stressed and the best
thing you can do for that little guy is
to get out of this debt and have margin
and so that needs to be your A1 of
course while taking care of them and
doing what you can do but this is going
to become a line a line item in the
budget the groceries might be a little
more expensive because we can't buy the
processed junk food anymore we've got to
get actual fruits and veggies and meats
and whatever and you might need a bigger
lined item for shopping to get some of
these things but I don't want you to
feel like this is a cycle that's forever
you get the waterproof mattress cover
once yeah you know and so the bigger
thing is getting this getting out of
this debt getting a full emergency fund
in place then making 70k we can manage
to cover those expenses for this guy and
get him uh get him to a better place
healthwise so we're wishing you the best
Leslie in this debt payoff Journey but
read the fine print with whatever I just
don't trust Chase with a 39 and 1/2t
pole and I don't think you should nice
Christmas song reference thank you well
that's what the credit card companies
are they're the grinches stealing your
Christmas Joy You're a Mean One Mr
Grinch and now we're off the air thanks
FCC I'm just kidding K got so nervous no
I wasn't nervous at all I just didn't
understand the joke that was actually
pretty good I'm not going to lie I
thought it was pretty decent given the
fact I didn't know I had to prepare for
that voice today the the studio audience
all enjoyed it I'm getting cheers encour
him America you all very much hey that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Ken Coleman all the
folks in the booth and you America we'll
be back before you know it in the
meantime spend wisely save intentionally
and give generously
[Music]
[Applause]
n